hallo ihr lieben freund und herzlich
willkommen zum sky anytime nutella in
alter so andere hna.de ja die haben sich
auch der bin ich ich bin der hd typ mit
dem haken dran
ich hasse diese komischen szene musste
ich die ganze zeit in virum schlängeln
durch schlingel du kannst es sehr gut
seiner stange tanzen und sich darum
schlängeln la doch man üblichen
abenteuer geträumt
die haben schon wieder geteilter steht
checkpoint uns kommt ein kribbeln nicht
ich schaffe das nicht mehr aber man darf
doch liegen damit auf der stelle aber du
kannst es trotzdem noch schaffen glaube
ich nie okay dann nicht wollen hier
komme
du willst dich jeder mal durch da
springt nicht einfach nur laufen und ich
habe ja auch noch etwas angestellt
bei mir war es noch heftiger sneak peek
einfach alter du bist trotzdem voll
schnell
ich fühle mich als wäre ich dran junge
noch viel heftiger alles also die ganze
drogen brand bandbreite erst langsam
gehen ich begleite dich nach hause
bei mir erwarte drink magical milch ja
bei mir ist schon weg
sie hielt mir die schöne milch ich habe
wir haben gerade genau zwei punkte ich
habe zwei gold jackpot ich traurig da
draufdrücken drückte mir drauf bei mir
jetzt bestimmt ebenso ein troll damit ja
auch kom kom kom kom kom de alter die
haben schon wieder alles kaputt gemacht
dadurch ich musste wieder fliegen aber
ich darf an der stelle hier fliegen
statt bayerische küche dran steht hier
das heißt wir sollten einfach jetzt nur
durch laufe ich erstmal ganz so einfach
laufen ja oder nein bitte nicht gleich
kommt ja der hammer kommen
elektrifizierte keeper oka ach ja das
war im trail auf drin
[Musik]
schnelllauftore läuft macht die tür
hinter dir zu anni dass gar keine
winterreifen hat auf ok laut forest lauf
ich hab's frauen technisch nicht drauf
[Musik]
ich habe natürlich jetzt gerade nicht
wirklich gesprochen
natürlich spreche hier gerade nur für
eine bombe ist totaler frauenheld ja
klar nacht nach quartierte stunde hat
einen anderen weg ja klar die nicht putz
lieber eine runde da ja okay und ich bin
mir da weißt du ja jetzt jetzt jessica
es keine blase nämlich kann also ist das
ich gehe weder mein doppel päckchen okay
ich bin direkt dem anbieter den mond an
ich erwarte ja heute doch besuchen
schau dir den mond an der mond ist an
den gewinner dann mutiger was von mo
ok ich finde dass er momentan auf
youtube etwas unnötig machen sich voll
wieder solche boni account an jeder mehr
und sondern mit dem kommentar heute im
amerikanischen video meinetwegen der typ
ist nennt sich dann barack obama yes we
can
was ist sonst ein fight zwischen angela
merkel chuck norris
wir haben milliarden und ein genauso
eingesehen nicht witzig unnötig wie
computer sich alle auf die idee wird das
gemacht
angefangen hat alles man kann er sich
neuerdings den namen bei youtube da so
machen er ja stimmt schon aber wollte
das mich auch einfach einfacher ja spaß
cornelius kräften und das habe ich dann
auch spaß macht da dachten alle wirklich
heiße so
wer auch bei krankheiten haben wir das
meine ich ja auch schon in der dritten
folge glaube ich dass da wirklich die
meinung der zweite folge
das war wirklich die meinung mancher
leicht beeinflussbar ist also die
glauben schon viel in der hinsicht so
kommst du nicht einfach mal runter also
habe ich gregor onken und dann dachte
ich alles krieg und trinken immer noch
aktiver checkpoint wenn wir nicht so
sicher ob man das hier mit aktivieren
kann
mein traum halten den schalter immer ich
hier nach alter der überlauf ich
schwimme einfach mal hier durch qualität
und so drüber hüpfen tts mit
sympathischer als diese komischen kipa
das ist ja auch gelb ich bin runter
gefallen aber ich komme wieder hoch na
du auch da stehe ich nicht noch wasser
geht man muss auf diesen komischen links
bleiben ja mach ich mir das schon okay
mit anlauf mit anlauf auf befehl hat
mich doch klappt hier drauf schade ich
wollte man hier eine auf profit uhren
und da einfach mal in eine mischform
gruber laufen aber ich glaube man kann
auch durch schwimmen wenn man von anfang
an durch schwimmt und ich mir zu einem
ruck dann sag ich mal wenn man nicht
trifft dann so gut geht ich das einfach
ich gerade machst du das mal ich probier
es trotzdem jetzt mit diesen komischen
kein einfach weil ich aufnehmen und euch
belieben bestandteile von crafter
kulturbanausen damals das alter ist ein
echt klasse schneeverwehungen sehe ich
gerade
es sieht echt aus ich hatte gerade lust
einfach mal so ein video davon zu drehen
man hört jetzt bestimmt und bei mir
überhaupt nicht ich habe bei mir ist gar
nichts man froh dass ich das war echt
krass also ich finde es eigentlich ganz
schön so wenn schnee draußen liegt
überrascht mich doch nur hat keine
schule ich kann die gleichen foto
einfach mal so ich fahre ja mal ich weiß
nicht vielleicht vergess ich es auch
möglich bei mir ist kein schnee bei mir
ist einfach stinknormales als ob ja ist
bei mir so bei mir ist der heftige
schneefall
bei mir war noch einmal in diese folge
oben rechts oder irgendwo ganz fett und
foto einblenden was ich jetzt gerade
mache um euch dann zu zeigen wie das bei
mir gerade aussieht und natürlich
fotografiert dass man ganz kurz so werde
ich werde nachher versuchen irgendwie
einzubinden wenn ich nicht vergesse
okay da sieht man es nicht dass das ein
heftiger schneefall ist aber okay ich
probiere es einfach mal später einen
verzicht auf was ich wert bei mir ist
überhaupt kein schnee
okay was ihr hier nein olé olé olé olé
ich habe eine krasse geschwindigkeit
drauf das schon mal sehr gut und ich
hab's geschafft und ich kann einfach
weiter schwimmen hier über das ist auf
jeden fall schon mal sehr schön und ich
habe es auch geschafft
ich bin ja nicht auf den fersen ich hol
dich einmal die knie
hier ist ein komischer goldener file so
dass eine falsche fach mal runter hier
gab es geschafft eine eisentür aber wir
müssen hier um güter bestimmt oder
hundertprozentig irgendwas online alte
schilder müssen wir lesen und ipads
chris liddell offen
was heißt wäre doch mal was entwurfs die
wars mir gebracht ist ein eigenes wort
von ihm glaube ich okay die leute die
insgesamt die mutter wohl irgend welchen
anderen leuten gegeben hier still have
not the water island ist sense gateways
mit dem zweierbob das ist eine
sagenhafte tippen die fans yourself wie
magic sword and follow dollar verloren
die magic quadrant and rescue deadlock
sowie sonstige zum schwert nehmen und
anderen jeden leser irgendwann guck dir
mal das schwert an was drauf hat und
laufe auf lauras eltern auflaufen alter
passau
es hat einfach alles drauf was es gibt
so krass hier können sich auch gut mal
in der folge hunger games gebrauchen
aber eigentlich nie im glück hängen geht
mit dem verzaubern
da kriege ich dann höchstens mal ja mods
scherwey 1 es gibt ja motto kriegs auf
seinen sohn schwer zum schneller abbauen
geht das überhaupt die items damit geht
das
okay was haben wir hier ich bin ich
schon weiter aha ja ich bin auch schon
bei dir
okay wir müssen die leitern hoch
klettern die tintenfische verarschen uns
wird gern wirklich gern mal dieses
schwert ausprobieren jetzt möchte ich
gerne dass irgendwelche treiber sind das
jetzt einfach mal testen kann
ach da geht schon um die ecke dachte
reserve läuft der konter an dem ich das
testen könnte aber die mache ich nicht
machst du nicht übernehmen alter krass
was ich brauche was hat man ich ich
selber gleich nein ich bin gleich tot
und explodiert gleich irgendwas okay
weil du solltest es noch schaffen bist
tot alter bin ich aber ich hab das
schwert wieder okay ich komm vorbei
folgen
ich folge dir auf twitter facebook vor
die augen sagen was du folgst mir hat
den schalter schon gedrückt und stetig
ausgedrückt ja das war aber nur tnt nur
ich kann ich jetzt wieder so toll
schlagen
ich weiß einfach mal den fuß hin in der
hoffnung dass mich das nicht schlägst
konnte schon noch mal ändern keine
balkone nicht ok ok power forward in
kleinen theater also okay die forschungs
bestimmten das ist wieder nicht die
butter insel things man das gibt's doch
nicht
hier steht etwas stinkt und das war ein
tintenfisch 51 es wird teurer heißt es
auf die schlichte könnten
ich bin ja soo schlecht und wir sollten
gerade jetzt die toilette finden in
denen ein schlüssel versteckt ist
das ist ja nicht mit dieser schlüssel
aussieht und wie wir ich habe noch sonne
einmal haben wir hier eine jetzt keiner
haye ist steckt in der toilette fest ein
glück nicht mehr geil
die karte ist irgendwie sondern toilette
mit links drauf also ja okay ich laufe
einfach weiter hier aber ich irgendwas
nicht hier ist auch nichts naja wir
müssen jetzt wirklich alles durch gucken
hier oder
das sei jedoch hatten einen verstärker
nicht verstellt er sich damit dem
schlüssel vor da juni machen level
muss ja jeder ist irgendwo drin oder
bist du denn abbauen oder wie da fragst
du mich was ich denke mal wir müssen den
finden in england lohaus hier vielleicht
muss ich jetzt in allen drin glaube ich
ich war auch schon in allen drin aber
[Musik]
ich war noch nicht in allen toiletten
ach ja wir müssen die toiletten und
damit andere ich brauchen ok schallt
okay
müssen oder auf den bäumen da kommt man
ja auf den einbau drauf vielleicht
sollten wir es doch einfach in die
toiletten mal versuchen reinzustellen er
habe ich schon probleme bei einigen aber
noch nicht bei allen vier beinen auf dem
baum drauf auf jeden fall näher man
darauf kommen dass andere sache auf
jeden fall
ist da oben ja gold und den leiter auf
den baum sehr verdächtigt verdächtigt
anschläge auch dich deutsch deutsch
deutsch
okay was haben wir hier noch eine
kloschüssel und wo noch eine kloschüssel
es ist ja immer konkreter handwerk nicht
mehr bleiben tür zu rom an ich finde
diesen lieber nicht
der war auch uns bestimmt nur wieder
hundertprozentig
ich versuche mal hier in die ganzen
sachen einzusteigen das wird
wahrscheinlich da hinten seinem rutschen
des twingo
kommen wir da nicht irgendwie drauf oder
so auf die bäume
ich denke immer noch hier muss doch
irgendwo ein schalter sollen eng hier
entweder vollen türen oder draußen in
der toilette der wird doch irgendwann
die sbornaja sowie ihr verschwinden wenn
man gegen die fünf minuten spielt dann
wird er einfach verschwinden
deswegen kann da eigentlich nicht im
monate seien wahrscheinlich ist irgendwo
eine toilette hinweg nach unten kann
aber auch nicht zahlen
geht gar nicht eigentlich aber ich weiß
nicht was momentan alles möglich ist
nicht meine ich weiß auch immer mal drin
wohnen anguckt dann der mond kann ja
schon verschiedene gesichter haben den
boden kann man kann alles und die körper
kommt alles alles geht eigentlich okay
ich sehe gerade dass man man man muss
auf jeden fall auf den baum irgendwie
drauf weil da ist und genau das meine
ich ja das ist eigentlich haben wir auf
diese toilette muss man eben drauf
kommen hier auf dieses häuschen
noch nie
über die tür geht nicht ja wir müssen
bestimmt backen damit wieder hochkommt
also ich hätte noch ein ei könnt ihr
einfach mal werfen ich hätte auch noch 2
ich komme aber nirgendwo mono mama helfe
ja da wirst du dich der einzige
das ist nicht irgendeine leiter oder so
nicht alter schwede ist die karte groß
die karte geht übrigens auch noch ein
bisschen ich habe da gab es schon
gesehen da oben ist auch da oben geht
noch sonderweg lang ich habe mal ganz
kurz hier moment und ich hier
weiterkommen schon leiter wofür wo bist
du mein freund marc ganz ganz ganz ganz
kurz vom server herunter so ein problem
ja weil die map hat irgendwie komisch
jetzt hat stimmt das relativ gesehen
haben wir das nur eins drauf nur wenn
nicht jetzt zum ende immer ab online das
einfach nur manchmal und für solche
sachen gut aber werde
wie machen wir weiter ich weiß es nicht
ich würde auch sagen dass du das jetzt
erst mal ganz kurz stoppen für die folge
jene genau suchen wir dann einfach in
der nächsten folge weiter und dann sehen
wir uns bei comma hat die in volkach
sagt doch einfach mal durchlesen komme
abgabe kommen
ich sag doch auch nicht konkreter mit
gummibärchen thema
immer bewährt das raster gefallen hat
und morgen ist dann die folge beide
hatten auf einer schar aus